bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bon début
de semaine on a depuis des semaines fait
le tour des problèmes du pont champlain
du futur pour jean pellet on vous a
également parlé des travaux au prochain
au pont tunnel louis hippolyte
lafontaine
or voici l'autre gros casse-tête
montréalais pour le ministère des
transports à québec
l'état déplorable de la portion
québécoise du pont mercier tellement
importants comme problème en fait qu'on
exclut pas en construire un tout nouveau
jean-sébastien cloutier rouler sur le
pont mercier et vous devinerez
facilement qu'il a besoin de réparations
la traversée par et parfois aventureuse
sur le tablier tu n'es pas mieux sa
structure d'acier a des allures les
quêtes particulièrement du côté de
montréal en direction sud est-ce que
tout est sur la table même peut-être un
nouveau ans n'écarte aucune possibilité
il y a trois ans la structure originale
du pont du côté nord nécessitait déjà
des travaux d'urgence et il y en a
encore aujourd'hui
sauf que tout ça risque d'être un
rafistolage en attendant la chirurgie
d'ici peu non une étude sera remise à
québec qui devra alors choisir la
meilleure solution à long terme pour sa
partie du pont c'est une des clés lancé
comme ça c'est une hypothèse la partie
provinciale pour être construites et
raccordé à la porte à la partie fédérale
où la partie provinciale pourrait par
l'objet de travaux de réfection majeure
peut-être plus important de ce qu'on est
déjà connu inauguré en 1934 cette
première structure du pont mercier
appartient au gouvernement du québec une
vingtaine d'années plus tard le fédéral
creuser la voie maritime du
saint-laurent et prolonger le pont vers
le sud
une deuxième structure plus large de
deux voix était donc inauguré en 1958
finalement en 63 à quelques mètres de la
partie originale du pont québec ajoutait
un autre tronçon du côté nord-est pour
s'arrimer avec les quatre voies au sud
on se retrouve donc aujourd'hui avec peu
pont provincial au nord plus mal en
point et un pont fédéral au sud la
partie fédérale est en train d'être
refaite 160 millions de
là ils ont été investis en cinq ans est
le tout nouveau tablier pose problème
c'est que la date qui va installer
justement du côté du fédéral
elle est trop lourde en fait paul l'état
de la structure donc sous le pont du
côté provincial de notre côté les
travaux ne sont pas fait de gaieté de
coeur la dalle de béton du pont doit
être remplacé alors c'est ainsi des
travaux qui étaient nécessaires
et comme pour illustrer cette complexité
qui a fait parfois la cohabitation
fédérale-provinciale voici sur la droite
la paix cyclable que le fédéral est en
train de construire de son côté au sud
elle s'arrêtera au milieu du pont et une
fois terminée elle ne mènera nulle part
avec des travaux concentré en était le
tablier la piste cyclable de la partie
chute du pont mercier seront terminés en
on risque alors de se retrouver avec une
moitié de pompes pratiquement neuve et
une autre au nord qui nécessitera des
années de travaux et de nouveaux
chantiers à endurer pour les
automobilistes
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal